[Music]
I first heard about humans from my
agents I think the words were something
like it's about robots and I immediately
thought I don't know if that sounds like
my kind of thing and I had visions of
sort of Steel
you know beings and then it seems I read
it I thought I know this is exactly my
kind of thing because it's a really
clever combination of sci-fi but rooted
in a domestic very recognizable world
and we weren't made out of metal and so
I read the scripts and I thought they
were the most interesting scripts I've
read in a really long time
[Music]
Hey
[Music]
before we started filming the very first
series we had a nice long stretch of
time at the studios with Dan O'Neill our
music director and we just went through
stage by stage kind of building up the
process of how a simple might move down
came with some ideas but we worked some
out kind of by doing it so looking at
what was the most efficient way of
moving and considering what would
conserve our battery power the most hi
thank you for joining us today we're
testing a new prototype of the MD model
we've made some adjustments what we're
doing is we're just charging her up now
and when she's fully charged we're going
to take her through some basic tests to
ensure that the product is the quality
we expect here and that she's ready for
the market hello Emily hello my name is
Dan hello Dan nice to meet you nice to
meet you Anthony I'm gonna take you
through some tests do you understand yes
good if you'd look forward please only
so the first thing we look for is
obviously a vocal and face recognition
that package is working clearly as we
expected this stage okay so I guess the
top of the movement director as opposed
to a choreographer I'd say it's easy to
say what choreographer is and then we
can work out what we've directories from
that so providers feel that someone who
is creating essentially dance or
movement and will often have a
distinctive signature or styles like an
artist like a painter you'll be able to
recognize their work as a movement
director as opposed to a choreographer
I'm working with the bodies and with the
context and with the story in the
narrative them with the director on how
best to tell that story but within the
are constraint in this situation is
synthetic hello I'm now in setup mode
and ready for primary use of bonding I'm
the primary user Joseph Hawkins Joe a
DNA sample will be taken for
identification and security purposes
information will never be shared with
any third party organization hello Joe
I'm now securely bonded to you as my
primary user it's very nice to meet you
okay a bit like a car there's a basic
format you know the car has wheels and a
steering wheel whether it's made a
hundred years ago or now that they've
pretty much got the same basic staff and
all since having the same basic rules
which is they stand in parallel there's
a certain eyeline there's an alignment
of the body carriage at the arms the way
they walk
and that's talk to the actors prior to
filming I was thinking what's the
examples of really great machines for us
out there in the world and it's kind of
us actually well it's sort of the most
sophisticated piece of kit out there as
far as I can see and so I thought well
why don't we just Center it on the human
body and just get the human body to work
as efficiently as was designed suddenly
everything there's a way to make that
decision so if you're standing up rather
than thinking how might an imaginary
robot that we've never heard of before
stand up you have the starting point of
what's the most economical way to stand
up that will use the least battery power
the program to be working ahead all the
time so she before she stands will know
what that feels like almost as a machine
and she'll stand in her exact height if
I stood up
I'd probably past my height and then
slumped down but Emily as you will see
will stand to her perfect synthe height
and return to the seat exactly as she
was before hopefully and would you stand
by a peripheral vision right out here
you know 175 degrees possibly some new
territories but we figured they'd be
more like cameras and walk and if you
try to do that with the lens it would
start distorting and bending so we
thought there - CCTV kind of cameras
like hundred twenty degrees each so a
synth conscious glance and see Tom over
there with this with the boom I'd have
to see him and then see you the eyeline
is is really what I would call the third
eye like in a mystical way and a gazes
directly into our eye lines so if you'd
look to your left please I'm now going
to ask her to look all the way to the
right but hopefully there won't be a
little pictures taken on the way she'll
just see immediately what needs to be
seen on the right hand side and it's
your right please and back to the center
blink blink as you can see the eyelids
work together we tend to as humans just
use our upper eyelid and if we slow that
motion down if you could close your eyes
please Emily and both eyelids will pop
open and she'll be in focus immediately
and open that's great that's working
really really well your chin is down and
your eye line is straight it means I can
see someone's feet without looking at
them so this eyeline was useful to argue
a case for health and safety for the
sins but also gave us a particular gaze
that is very straight into the human eye
something that we're not used to which
means that the actors initially the
human acts is very disconcerted by this
steady unblinking gaze one thing's been
really interesting is the status that
being a synth in public gives you if I
walk down the street I always seem to be
the person that's dodging and out the
way and being like sorry excuse me if
you just walk down the street as a synth
people move out of your way because your
intention is so clear that I am going
from here to there that other things
just sort of happen around you and I
noticed that if I try and speak as a
synth not using any superfluous words
and
and ours and so on that I do normally
well I suppose people probably find it a
bit frightening and intimidating but it
definitely feels that you sort of get
your point across really quickly and
clearly and people are more likely to do
what you say hello mrs. Hawkins
I am Stanley I'm happy for you we've got
a parcel law I've been appointed by Her
Majesty's Government to act as your
domestic and professional assistant
personal security detail and driver for
the duration of the Dryden Commission
it's very misty the real acid test for
me is if you think this in synthetics
without doing the green eyes it's that
other quality that I think the producers
were looking for the directors looking
for we have broken some of the
conventions on occasions but we've
always found a rationale for that and
not broken the key ones because I think
once you do that it's very hard to put
it back together again and build the
trust that this meant that that this
thing is real although we're doing
obviously a drama it does also know some
trivia so let's just see if this package
is working while she's up do you know
what the weather is going to be like
today the weather in London today will
be lows of four degrees and highs of
seven degrees with a 30% chance of rain
is that here yes and where are we we are
in Barking Essex thank you it's been one
of the biggest challenges making this
balance between how a synthetic can move
and the kind of range of facial
expressions and voice range that they
might have and balancing that with
something that is thinking and feeling
and conscious and particularly to begin
with I've constantly found that quite a
difficult balance that in order to
achieve the stakes of a scene or to feel
like the audience might really
understand what my character was feeling
I felt quite restricted so one thing
that was really useful in terms of
finding that balance was working with
William Hurt in the first series he was
playing a human
I was watching him and he's for a long
time being one of my favorite actors and
he doesn't do any superfluous physical
or facial work nothing demonstrative and
so I just thought right with that that
is what good acting is and you just need
to have your thoughts so clear and if
anything it means I have to come in a
hundred times more prepared with the
scene and with an understanding of kind
of the depth of feeling or the stakes
for the character so that then when you
put the synthetic stuff on top of it
you don't end up with nothing down is
really good at encouraging us to just
trust that the audience will understand
you don't need to add anything else so
I've tried really hard to take that into
my other work actually I'm going to ask
you to demonstrate running what we're
looking for here the head should be
completely still and that there's this
low chopping arm action it's similar to
the athlete Michael Johnson that very
upright very distinctive way of running
and it means that the faster the hands
chop the faster the legs move this model
will reach twenty six point seven miles
an hour which is sinless or the speed
see new same bolt so that's your
standard speed of a of a running synth
so let's demonstrate that for me please
sir Emily would you run to the other
side of the room thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this is my funniest thing actually
because it's something they can do for
themselves and it's an experience that
they take away you're leaving the
building you know you're gonna go to a
tube station and you know there's an
oyster card reader all I want you to
think about for when you leave the
building is the oyster card reader just
image that and the journey is completely
superfluous it's just not imp don't
invest in it so don't look at the no but
lost tourists all that cute guy or girl
all that obstacle think only of the
oyster reader and you write the oyster
reader and you place it waste a card on
it - you feel less exhausted the journey
sort of take care of itself
I mean people you get very strange
responses because you'll not give
anything back to people you're not
recognising them because answer you're
not being drank you'll just be focused
before the second and third series we've
come back and done a refresher with down
just to make sure the movement things
are back up to speed and I know I have
and the other guys do as well we'd sort
of spend a bit of time at home doing the
washing-up as a simple game in the few
weeks building up to filming and walking
down the streets and just trying to get
it back into your body so it's not
completely alien on the first day when
the new axe has come on they're like
okay I've done since school with dad and
we did that a couple of hours and I
might work with them again and then I
institution to the existing company and
when they meet someone like Joe machan
who's in role they suddenly think oh my
god I've got to be that good because he
really when you're close up then it is
quite shocking what they can do
I do not wish to be powered down I wish
to continue with the test but the test
is completed Emily sorry about it
embarrassing Emily I would like to power
you then do not wish to be powered down
I wish to continue with the test um
sorry I mean this is all right this is
why the problems we have with the Emily
it's quite a willful model of all the
other people in this room down there
just people who are observing the tests
Emily would you please cooperate you
have not introduced me to these people
okay Emily is a very social model so yes
I'll introduce them to you okay now I
can pair you down yes
okay so we have suze on this camera here
hello we have Darren hello I'm Georgina
hello I've broken hello this is Tom
hello this is Rosie hello Debra hello
and this is sheriff hello
you may pound me down okay
okay thank you very much at a time I
hope that's been interesting for you
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]